so recreational Cannabis the first
dispensary is set to open in New York
today it's called Housing Works cannabis
company it is in lower Manhattan and
it's one of the first to get its
dispensary retail license it's operated
by the non-profit Housing Works known
for helping the homeless and the
formerly incarcerated and also people
living with HIV and AIDS adults age 21
and older will be able to buy legally
recreational marijuana in New York New
York state has approved 36 cannabis
dispensary licenses so recreational
Cannabis the first dispensary is set to
open in New York today it's called
Housing Works cannabis company it is in
lower Manhattan and it's one of the
first to get its dispensory retail
license it's operated by the non-profit
Housing Works known for helping the
homeless and the formerly incarcerated
and also people living with HIV and AIDS
adults age 21 and older will be able to
buy legally recreational marijuana in
New York New York state has approved 36
cannabis dispensary licenses